from Politico Trump haphazardly stashed
military Secrets throughout his home
indictment says prosecutors charged
Trump with 37 felonies including 31
counts under the Espionage Act of
willful retention of classified records
37 felonies
I mean this is this is breakdown of of
political and social order in the United
States yeah and then how many they have
in New York I can't remember how many
was that was that seven yeah something
like that you know it
the timing on this is so interesting
right it's literally the day that the
that the republicans in Congress
announced that they have Biden dead to
rights on the barisma bribe deal
same exact day and we knew it the whole
time it was a remarkable moment on this
show like to give a shout out to our
friend Hunter Avalon when I brought up
that Joe Biden said if you don't fire
the prosecutor you're not getting the
loans and he goes that never happened
and I was like that's on video I pulled
the video and I'm like there's the video
of it happening and it's it's remarkable
to me how many people are willing to
upon in the Ukraine conflict without
having done the research into the
barisma Scandal uh uh the cutter turkey
pipeline gas prom Etc we we've been
talking about this for some time I went
through Ukrainian Russian British French
and U.S news reports tracking down what
was going on I went through Wikipedia
which is I know not the best but I'm
trying to connect the dots and the dots
are are pretty clear the guy who was
running barisma you got a former CIA guy
on the board you got Hunter Biden on the
board it is clear that there is
something nefarious going on when when
Biden came out and said you know we want
to fire the prosecutor because he wasn't
good and then he gets fired and they put
someone good in lies this CEO of barisma
was was had fled the country when the
and the prosecutor had about a dozen or
more this is according to Matt Tybee
open investigations into my colas
lechevsky and barisma
when the prosecutor got fired
those those investigations go away
zlachevski returns to the country he was
the CEO lacheski he's the founder I
think he was CEO he's the founder yeah
when uh when Trump then starts asking
questions what's going on flees the
country again yeah yeah but so so when
Biden's intervention resulted in the guy
coming back right nonsense this it is
clear as day and so that drops the exact
same day as this not to mention
how many boxes does Biden have next to
his Corvette in his garage yeah I mean
like what the hell are we talking about
here I mean you know this is this is so
obviously political and this department
of justice has been so politically
motivated now for so many years I mean
we've seen it I mean how many
investigations into Trump right oh
Russia collusion fake totally fake
everybody knows that it's fake now right
and so now here we are on this one as
well I hope everybody knows that it's
fake if it's fake because I don't I I
have a feeling that 70 million people
have no idea I think I think you're
right about that but I bet everybody in
this room knows it's fake I believe it's
fake Teflon Don every many people have
taken shots at him he's gone through
many like impeachments and whatnot I
can't even remember all the scandals but
uh it seems as though they're saying
there's like a Smoking Gun here where
there's this transcript in the
indictment where it's saying that he's
talking to a staffer about declassifying
when he's not able to have you seen this
stuff and do you think think this will
be the one that gets him or let me just
real real quick hey you want to buy a
bridge from me if it's cheaper though I
don't know do you have a deal for me
yeah yeah do I think this one's gonna
stick I don't
um I I don't think it's gonna stick and
I will tell you in the in the psyche and
the conscious of the American people out
here who are not kind of like
brainwashed into thinking that uh Trump
colluded with Russia and all these other
things
um I I don't think they're going to
believe this either I mean how many of
these things are going to keep coming up
that they're going to try to get him on
um to answer your question in New York
he's been charged with 34 felony counts
yes 34 felony counts in New York and
nothing came of that this is the first
former president to be criminally
indicted as I understand uh many people
say this will escalate with a Tit for
Tat once a republican you want to see
different former Democrats
um indicted on things well I'm sure they
could find this stuff with Joe Biden but
would you like to see Democratic uh
former presidents also
um search through and possibly I mean
not in any political manner but look if
they have broken the law then yes I mean
then yes look I mean people need to be
answerable to the law and I mean our
current president uh certainly isn't it
a good a good prosecutor could indict
Iraq is you know one of the sayings if
you have a good prosecutor you could
find anything to indict on so that's why
I kind of ask it becomes political once
they start indicting Republicans and
then them trying to do it back to them
so on that yeah and that's in the first
time you've seen this right so they
started uh started down this path and
piecing with the Richard Nixon and then
they came back in Revenge on Bill
Clinton right I mean so you you've seen
some of this before but it's like you've
gone through two impeachments to Trump
you've gone through all these
investigations and all the I mean it is
it one sense though I'd say what's very
interesting about it is that it shows
you the power of the deep state it shows
you how powerful they are and it is
exposing who is actually in charge here
absolutely it's
Joe Biden every day it's Joe Biden it's
the Relentless nature of the
organization me saying Joe Biden was in
charge is a joke and everyone left man I
saw a video of them the day just
staggering around on stage with a vacant
stare and then I saw his profile and it
looked really like a fat chick it's Mr
Magoo's our president yeah man that show
was funny and that's it indicate like
why is the justice department going
going sideways well we have no
leadership or a lack of leadership like
a good president no matter who you are
is going to know that you don't want to
disrupt and destroy your political
establishment if you're part of the deep
state right now and you're working there
this is like the greatest Time of Your
Life yeah oh this is great very little I
mean you're just left your own devices
it's all political appointees and people
that have been there forever that are
just having the time of their life and
they're getting a lot done uh
unfortunately and I mean it's
unfortunate for all the people in
America but I will say this about Hunter
Hunter
could play a very critical role in
ending the war in Ukraine I do believe
all he would have to do I think for us
like a brief period of time given the
nature of his consumption boycott
perhaps Russian liquor and hookers and
the war's over
I mean I think it would have an effect
on the economy that would be
irreversible perhaps
like that Putin would fly him out yeah
Hunter we need you back please
how do you feel about this Warren
Ukraine situation how what kind of
resolution do you see
you know I I think the unfortunate thing
is that you're not seeing and of course
out of this Administration there seems
to be no diplomatic overtures whatsoever
uh to try to end the war in Ukraine and
there needs to be some type of
negotiated end to this if you think that
the ukrainians are going to be able to
categorically and strategically defeat
the Russian military and defeat Russia
that's not a likely outcome right and so
they need to be in a position where
there can be some type of negotiated
peace settlement here the ukrainians
though for them they want Crimea back
they want the Don bass you know
I don't know if that's necessarily
possible but there needs to be some type
of diplomatic overtures from our
secretary of state who seems to be is
anybody seen him Tony blanken the
Secretary of State I I hear nothing from
him nothing from him on this I feel like
I've heard more from like Henry
Kissinger who's like a hundred right I
mean like he's talked about this more
than than Tony blanken it's funny you
mentioned that because Tony blinken
actually went to Henry Kissinger's 100th
birthday in New York City like sometime
last week not to derail the conversation
too aggressively but I think it kind of
relates to this President Joe Biden has
said that if Taiwan is attacked by China
then we will defend them do you think
the United States should come to the
defense of Taiwan if attacked by China
yeah I I think that there is a we do
have to deter China as it relates to
Taiwan and I think that there can be
deterrence in that because you're
talking about a massive area that is
hugely important to the United States as
it relates to the economy of the United
States right but deterrence is the key
here I mean somebody said a long time
ago if you want peace prepare for war
isn't it if you say we will defend
Taiwan that would be setting deterrence
then so can we get a yes or no answer I
mean deterrence is different than War
Well we'd be deterring China by telling
them that we would come to the defense
of Taiwan yes but deterrence is also
power projection right so we I'll give
you a great example we deterred the
Soviet Union for decades right I mean
that was the detaunt that was the
deterrent strategy there deterrence can
be uh a viable option here because
they're going to make the calculation
because for them they're going to have
to look to see
okay they're going to take air strikes
into Taiwan eventually they will have to
put boots on the ground in an amphibious
and salt right but then they're also
going to have to take out our Assets in
uh third Fleet right who's out there in
the Pacific that is going to then incur
massive casualties on their side and
ours amphibious they've not done
amphibious Invasion right so they're
trying to think that Hundred Mile
Stretch that they're going to have to
cross what that looks like we have to
make that calculation as difficult as
humanly possible for them so if I just
could Joe Biden has repeatedly said that
we will militarily intervene if Taiwan
is attacked by China do you agree with
Joe Biden or disagree I feel like I know
we could put a lot of but at the end of
the day like yeah I mean
that statement is like so basic I guess
it's what he says is why I'm asking it
kind of specifically like that yeah I
mean
it's like with anything with him it's
like it's such a basic answer it's like
we should like but his answer should be
is like we should deter China from
invading Taiwan he'd argue that he's
deterring them by saying that he would
come to their defense and Trump trump
did something similar yeah Trump
famously bragged that he told Xi Jinping
that and Putin that he would nuke uh
what did he say Shanghai and Moscow I
think he was in Moscow and he was like
and you know they don't really believe
me maybe five percent but it was enough
yeah and that was like I'm like man I
like Trump that would I get why he's
doing it if it stops the war yes
and that's the thing we have to the the
stated objective here is
for me to stop War like we don't want a
war thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time